Bitte schön.
Ein bekannter Kollege.
Hallo Doktor, Sie sind wieder.
Hallo.
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Sedat Ulta.
Ich bin auch der Stationale Asstätich.
Ich möchte das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Aber natürlich.
Bitte schön, Herr Kollege.
Sie waren auch letzte Woche schon mal da.
Ich kann mich an Sie erinnern.
Bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Klaus Remele.
Bitte buchst du ab, wenn ich es langsame.
Also Klaus mit K, L, A, U, S, Klaus Remele.
Wie man sagt, also Richard, Emil, Martha, Martha.
Emil Ludwig, Emil, Remele.
Okay.
Herr Remele.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 3. April, 1900.
Was ist das?
74?
73.
79.
Nee, 83.
Entschuldigung.
83.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Remele?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
2,82 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
85 kg.
Okay, schön.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausast?
Das ist der Herr Krakow.
Ja, Krakow.
Der ist in der Schulstraße.
Okay, schön.
Herr Remele, was würdest du uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Also Herr Doktor, ich habe seit einigen Tagen, das nimmt immer mehr zu,
im linken Unterbauch Schmerzen, die immer wieder mal kommen und gehen,
mal mehr, mal weniger mit den Schmerzen.
Aber das wird nicht besser.
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Linken Unterbauch.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie sehr brennend, drückend oder kloffend?
Ja, nicht mal so brennend, aber eher so ein bisschen dumpf.
Und manchmal eher so wellenartig.
Es kommt und geht.
Und je nachdem, wie stark diese Wellen sind,
sind auch die Schmerzen sehr stark oder ein bisschen weniger.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einem Skala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei sind für sehr starke Schmerzen.
Gestern waren sie wirklich sehr, sehr stark.
Da würde ich schon sagen, 7, 8.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen auch in die Leiste?
Ja, also wenn das sehr starke Schmerzen sind,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, es geht so ein bisschen in die Leiste.
Und manchmal strahlt es auch so ein bisschen in den linken Hoden rein.
Aber eigentlich ist es mehr im linken Unterbauch, würde ich sagen.
Seit einigen Tagen?
Ja.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen schon einmal gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich solche Schmerzen habe.
Wenn die Schmerzen kommen, steigen Sie langsam oder treten Sie plötzlich?
Also jetzt, wenn Sie auftreten, dann treten Sie plötzlich auf.
Herr Römerle, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verbessert oder verschrieben werden?
Zum Beispiel Körperhaltung essen und bewegen?
Nein, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Das hat also nichts mit speziellen Körperhaltungen zu tun.
Und haben Sie eine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Ja, also ich habe mir zweimal schon ein paar Rezettamol genommen.
Das hilft ein bisschen, aber so ganz weg geht es nicht.
Haben Sie auch andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Müdigkeit, Übelkeit, Erbrechen?
Erbrechen jetzt nicht, aber so eine leichte Übelkeit habe ich.
Müssen Sie nachts Wasser lassen, Herr Römerle?
Nachts jetzt nicht, aber wenn diese wellenartigen Schmerzen kommen,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich muss auch öfters auf Toilette er.
Haben Sie auch Probleme und Veränderungen beim Wasser lassen,
zum Beispiel auch brennende Schmerzen?
Oder wenn Sie gehen, müssen Sie nur ein bisschen...
Nein, nein.
Also Sie haben kein Problem mit Wasser lassen?
Haben Sie viel Beuschelstufolst oder Nachts Schweiß?
Nein, solche Symptome habe ich jetzt nicht.
Super.
Herr Römerle, haben Sie in letzter Zeit umgewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, also mit meinem Gewicht bin ich eigentlich immer stabil.
Ja, super.
Und dann hat sich Ihr Appatit verändert?
Appetit? Nein.
Aber das ist gleichgeblieben, da haben jetzt keine Veränderungen.
Und wir haben schon etwas über Wasser lassen gesprochen
und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang? Nein, also da hat sich eigentlich auch nichts geändert.
Wegemässig?
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Oh, leider nicht. Ich würde gerne, aber nein.
Okay, ich verstehe das.
Herr Römerle, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe als Kind mal die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Und ich hatte mal schon mal einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Da bin ich vor sieben Jahren ungefähr, ich glaube, das waren sieben Jahren,
auch an der Bandscheibe mal operiert worden.
Ja, wahrscheinlich vor sieben Jahren.
Ja, ungefähr.
Okay, verstehe.
Und leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen? Nein, an sich jetzt nicht, nein.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Heuchschlupfen, was jetzt wieder kommt,
aber ansonsten nein.
Ja, genau.
Und Herr Römerle, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentlich
Medikamente ein?
Also regelmäßig jetzt nicht, aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe,
dann hilft mir ein paar Zetamol.
Und dann, manchmal brauche ich auch mal Nobelgehend,
aber ansonsten kein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, wie gesagt, nur auf Berlin.
Ja, in den Frühlingsmonaten.
Bitte? In den Frühlingsmonaten, genau.
Ja.
Und, okay, rachen Sie Herr Römerle?
Nein.
Und zählen Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu mal, vor allem.
Wie oft würde Sie sagen pro Woche ein, zwei, vielleicht?
Also ich würde sagen, mein Wein zum Essen mache ich immer gerne.
Und am Wochenende auch mal ein bisschen mehr.
Da gehe ich gerne mal mit Freunden aus.
Und dann trinken wir auch mal etwas mehr.
Okay.
Ich möchte betonen, dass das eine Routinefrage ist,
bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder andere Substanzen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also Alkohol.
Und Herr Römerle, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Was meinen Sie damit, eine Grund für eine Erkrankung?
Die Erkrankungen, die nicht vollständig geheilt werden,
zum Beispiel Brutzkrankheit,
als Bluthoffdruck, Magen, Leberheitserkrankungen.
Also, also jetzt aus meinem Direkten,
ungefähr nicht, aber mein Onkel,
der hat, glaube ich, ein Prostata-Krebs oder gehabt.
Und meine Tante, die hat Brutzkrebs gehabt.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja.
Und Sie sind gesund?
Ja, so weit Sie nehmen mit der Familie.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was,
aber Sie sind so weit gesundheitlich stabil.
Ich habe aktuell keine Beschwerden
und es geht Ihnen gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder her.
Ein Bruder.
Und ist er auch gesund?
Er ist gesund.
So weit ich habe Probleme.
Okay.
Und zwei Römerle, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich bin Herr Römerle.
Ich habe zwei Kinder, ein Sohn und eine Tochter.
Und haben Sie zusammen?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Schreiner.
Ich montiere Küchen und Tische usw.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Das war meine Frage zu Ihren Beschwerden.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, also die Schmerzenmedikamente
reichen nicht mehr aus.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Deswegen bin ich hier.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie herausfinden, was es ist.
Okay, das kann ich sehr gut feststellen.
Ich denke, es gibt eine Institution
und eine Pedastdiagnose.
Zum sichern sollen wir
Blutabnehmen und körperliche Untersuchungen durchbeun,
ihre Profitaparameter messen.
Vielleicht brauchen wir gegebenenfalls
Tomorra Fürder im Etat.
Aber nachdem ich die Ergebnisse habe,
werde ich mit dem Oberjahrs darüber besprechen
und danach melde ich mich bei Ihnen.
Ich werde alle Fragen Schritt für Schritt erklären.
Okay.
Dann bin ich froh, ich denke, dass ich hier
an der richtigen Adresse bin.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie bald Wasser ausfinden.
Vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch
eine Frage?
Hat sich das Geruch oder die Farbe
des Urings verändert?
Ach so, nein, das bin ich aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber? Nein.
Das können wir als ansprechende anfangen.
Ja, ich habe eine schöne.
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberhardt.
Wir haben eine neue Patientin.
Herr Klaus Lehmeler, ich würde über ihn besprechen.
Haben Sie Zeit dafür?
Ja, ich bin schon.
Herr Klaus Lehmeler ist ein 42-jähriger Patient.
Er ist 1,82 Meter und 85 Kilogramm.
Der Patient stellte sich mit weit einigen Tagen bestehenden,
brennenden Wellenförmigen
in der linken Leiste ausstrahlenden
Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ja, das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Ich habe einen kleinen,
brennenden Unterbauchschmerzen.
Der 2. Klickte er über Nasch.
Ja, er klickte über Nasch.
Das ist der 1. Mal,
dass er diese Schmerzen gehabt.
Parastomol-Einnahme führt
zu leichter Verbesserung.
Ja.
Vegetativ an einem Neues ist unauffällig.
Die Schmerzinterste ist 7 bis 8.
Von 10 auf der Schmerzkale.
Ja.
Und Erkrankungen.
Zustand nach dyskectomien als Kind.
Und dyskectomie.
Zustand nach dyskectomien vor 7 Jahren.
Und die Schmerz-Kaline.
Ja, das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Er ist 11 Jahre alt.
Er leidet an allergischen Renates
in Prülexmonaten.
Er ist auch nicht.
Er trinkt Alkohol.
Er ist gelegentlich mit Freunden.
Er trinkt abends ein Glas Wein.
Als Familienamnese.
Unkel hat
Prostatakasinum.
Und seine Tante
Mamakasinum.
Er hat eine gesunde Bruder.
Verheiratet.
Unser Patient ist verheiratet.
Er hat ein Tochter und lebt zusammen mit ihrer Familie.
Er ist Schreiner vom Beruf.
Okay, gut.
Und, was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Die Analyse deutet auch Urulitisin.
Er hat...
Okay, Sie denken, das ist ein Anleiterstein.
Okay, ein Nierenstein.
Bitte von der Symptomatik passen.
Ja, er hat...
Was machen Sie für Untersuchungen, um das zu bestätigen oder aufzuschließen?
Bei einem kölpelischen Untersuchung
Klopfschmerzen ist wichtig.
Percussion der Nähe den Lages.
Ja, okay.
Urin-Untersuchung machen Sie ganz einfach, natürlich.
Ja, Urindiagnostisch.
Wir können Urinstext-Tests machen.
Vielleicht gibt es Hematuröpia,
Proteinuri oder Bakterivir.
Wir können das feststellen.
Als Diagnose können wir auch Sonografie durchspüren.
Jawohl.
Gegebenenfalls CT, Abdomen.
Jawohl, CT ist gut.
Okay, also das eine Diagnose,
das sind weitere Diagnose?
Vielleicht das kann die Werte kritis sein.
Lechte Diagnose.
Ja, das ist gut.
Lechte Diagnose,
Linke unterwärtschmerzen.
Vielleicht die Vertikulierung.
Aber er hat kein Problem mit dem Sturrgang.
Aber da würde ich trotzdem welche Laborwerte
wollen Sie da kontrollieren?
Blutbild,
vielleicht gibt es eine Annäme oder nicht oder
oder wir können Fakal-Ukut-Bluetest machen.
Entzündungswerte für die Kontrolle gehen, ne?
Ja, auch Entzündungswerte, Parameter ja, Leukosytos,
wie bei Prokasten in der ERP,
Blutzenkungengeschwindigkeit.
Und welche Untersuchungen können wir noch machen
um eine Divertin-Kolitis zu bestätigen
oder noch mal besser darzustellen?
Welche Diagnostik ist gut?
Ähm,
eine Skopä-Pilafik,
eine Koloskopi mal.
Ich könnte es sehen.
Noch vorher.
Eine CT, eine CT, CT und Computertumor.
Ah, CT, ja, okay.
Dann sehen Sie auch, ob eine Divertin-Kolitis vorliegt
oder nicht vorliegt.
Okay, gut, woran denken Sie noch? Differenzialdiagnose.
Ich würde extra ein bisschen kritisieren, aber da ist ein Mann.
Ja, da wird es ein bisschen schwierig, genau.
Vielleicht ein Wandlung gemacht, aber...
Ja, vielleicht ein bisschen kritisiert.
Er hat nicht die typische Schmerz, nur typische Bild, aber...
Keine Oberwarschmerzen, keine Gütelförmigenschmerzen.
Und es ist links unten in der Leiste.
Was kann an der Leiste noch sein, was ein bisschen Schmerzen machen kann?
Süßtet es?
Aber das auch Handwerks- und Klicks.
Genau, Süßtet es, aber eher linke Leiste.
Was ist an der Leiste? Was klemmt da manchmal ein?
Äh...
Ah, Testestosium, vielleicht?
Ein Zweifel, ich glaube.
Ob da...
Ja, deine Kollegen haben gute Ideen.
Genau, eine Herrne, also ein Leistenbruch.
Benannt man das eine inkarzerierte Leistenherne, kann das manchmal sein?
Einzige Leisten, ja.
Und Herrne, genau, also ein Leistenbruch.
Da muss man mal denken, richtig.
Und natürlich an chronisch entzündliche Dameckrankungen.
Ja, morgenskönig ist das.
Ja, aber ist es so, dass du zur Rose sagen kannst, ich glaube, das reicht, oder?
Ja, ja.
Vielen Dank für Ihr Hilfe.
Okay, haben die Kollegen oder Kollegen die vielleicht noch Fragen?
Oder Vorschläge?
Keine Frage?
Warum?
Sehr gut.